pour en savoir plus on va en parler avec
notre invité Marc féno mise de
l'agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire qui est notre invité
aujourd'hui bonjour merci d'être avec
nous et on va commencer par une image
qui a marqué cet été ce sont des
hectares de forêts détruits par des
incendies on va aller voir là c'est
l'image qui résume cet été 2022 on peut
le dire 60 000 hectares ravagés par les
flammes ce sont des pertes
environnementales c'est certain ce sont
des pertes économiques aussi ont-elles
été évaluées elles sont en cours
d'évaluation c'est vrai que c'est des
pertes à la fois environnementales et
des pertes économiques elles sont en
cours d'évaluation pourquoi parce que il
y a un certain nombre de forêts dont on
peut valoriser le bois même s'il a été
brûlé donc la première urgence c'est de
nettoyer les parcelles à l'automne et
d'essayer de valoriser ce qui peut
l'être ça a été fait d'ailleurs sur un
certain nombre de cases qu'on peut
évaluer par exemple le coût de la
réplation ça c'est juste un coup une
partie seulement des incendies du
Sud-Ouest girond des Landes c'est
environ 100 millions d'euros donc ça a
un coût de replantation mais la
l'urgence c'est d'abord de valoriser ce
qui peut l'être de nettoyer les
parcelles pour préparer la replacer ça
demande forcément un peu de temps c'est
normal parce qu'il faut que au fond la
nature repr
stabilise si je peux dire et donc on
sera au rendez-vous comme le président
de la République l'a dit de la
reconstruction de ces massif puis il
faut qu'on ait une réflexion avec les
mêmes essences d'art parce que on sait
bien c'est ce que j'allais dire il y a
des arbres qui brûlent plus vite globale
sur les essences sur l'organisation des
massifs pour lutter mieux contre les
incendies de forêt c'est valable dans le
sud-ouestances qui c'est qui pourraient
interdites par exemple ou qui pourrait
aussi orienter on peut aussi former on
peut aussi faire en sorte et les
forestiers le savent depuis des années
puisqu'il y a un plan de replantation
qui est en route qui a été décidé sous
le précédent quinquennat c'est plus d'un
milliard de d'euros qui a été fait pour
faire évoluer les essences ici c'est les
incendies parfois c'est du dépérissement
forestier je pense à l'est et donc il
faudra aller dans ce sens là et puis
alors il faut qu'on ait permettez-moi
juste dire un mot qu'on ait une culture
du risque incendie qui monte en latitude
parce que finalement on était plutôt sur
le Sud-Ouest vous connaissez le risque
de la forêt et le sud-est mais désormais
on voit bien que en Bretagne que dans la
région que je connais le mieux la région
Centre-Val de Loire que la région Pays
de Loire voisine on a eu des incendies
massifs dans le Jura et cette culture là
il faut qu'on arrive à la développer
c'est à dire qu'on est des outils des
moyens alors justement il y a en ce
moment un plan de suppression de poste à
l'office national des forêt qui est sous
votre tutelle d'ici 2025 500 emplois
vont être supprimés au vu de la
situation est-ce que vous le maintenez
ce plan mais on regardera les choses en
fonction de ce qu'on demandera à
l'Office National des Forêts il est
jeunes attendez sur les il y a un moment
budgétaire on en parlera au moment
budgétaire mais la question de l'ONF
c'est une question centrale puisqu'on
est effectivement j'en ai la tutelle
avec mon collègue Christophe Béchu c'est
la question des moyens humains c'est
aussi la question des moyens de
replantation c'est les questions des
moyens matériels et donc est-ce que vous
avez besoin et je rappelle que sur les
62000 hectares aujourd'hui qui ont brûlé
vous savez combien de massifs forestiers
publics qui ont brûlé non à peine 4000
hectares donc il faut qu'on travaille
sur la forêt public et il faut aussi
qu'on travaille sur la forêt privée pour
aider aussi les vraies questions et donc
c'est un masque global est-ce que le gel
des 500 suppressions d'emplois
alors du jour est-ce que vous permettez
qu'on regarde avec un peu de toutes les
moyens il faut qu'on regarde les moyens
donc on a besoin il faut qu'on regarde
les moyens dont on a besoin avec
pragmatisme c'est ça qui compte
de 500 postes ce sera moins on regardera
parce que il y a des besoins d'ailleurs
l'OMF intervient aussi dans le privé
pour donner des conseils on va voir mais
justement mais laissons le temps de
regarder les choses c'est pas un temps
qui durera des années mais regardons les
besoins on verra on verra les besoins là
sécheresse qui crée des situations
d'être chez agriculteurs il demande de
l'aide et dans le même temps des
assurances associations écologistes
notamment des noms certaines méthodes de
culture
était 2022 les agriculteurs conjuguent
sécheresse et des tresses
elles vont pas se nourrir avec ça quoi
vous voyez la crevasse ici on arrive à
rentrer sa main dedans
aussi fort on n'a jamais vu là on tape
déjà dans les stocks de cet hiver on va
devoir vendre des bovins des vaches pour
parce qu'on pourra pas les nourrir quoi
c'est quand même malheureux surtout que
c'est des bonnes bêtes
automatiquement s'il y a moins d'eau il
y a moins d'herbe donc forcément les
vaches vont me produire moins de lait le
manque de haut pour les cultures
maraîchères mais surtout c'est réalières
poussent des exploitants à arroser
malgré l'interdit ici le maïs faut qu'on
parle vite dans la famille on a des on a
des charges à payer les engrais qui ont
augmenté on était obligé de de faire ce
qu'on a fait c'est pas bien on en est
conscient tous mais on le fait la colère
des hommes face à la gestion de l'eau
pour son premier été le nouveau ministre
de l'Agriculture fait face à toutes les
calamités d'un secteur vous avez cette
année des gens qui ont pris gel grêle
grêle sécheresse
et qui peuvent se retrouver à avoir
perdu 20% de leur production puis 40%,
puis 80% puis 100% nous sommes une
puissance agricole qu'on peut pas
laisser les agriculteurs dans des
situations de difficultés des
difficultés qui ne touchent pas
seulement l'agriculture devant le
Conseil des ministres Emmanuel Macron
prend les Français à témoin pour ma part
que ce que nous sommes en train de vivre
et plutôt de l'ordre d'une grande
bascule ou d'un grand bouleversement
d'abord parce que nous vivons et cela
pas simplement depuis cet été ces
dernières années au fond la fin de ce
qui pouvait apparaître comme une
abondance
il y a des risques sur les questions
énergétiques mais on va pas manquer de
d'alimentation la première
responsabilité du Président de la
République c'est lui qui c'est de dire
les choses il a dit Emmanuel Macron fin
de l'abondance alors moi je vais vous
poser la question en tant que ministre
de la souveraineté alimentaire faut-il
craindre la fin de l'abondance
alimentaire en France on mange bien on
produit bien est-ce qu'un jour c'est ce
que dit la grande distribution déjà on
va manquer de lait d'huile de viande on
manque pas en quantité en production
initiale même si on a une récolte qui
est plus faible ça montre d'ailleurs que
quand on a une puissance exportatrice
quand les périodes sont moins bonnes on
garde de quoi se nourrir donc il faut
pas simplement assurer son besoin il
faut assurer un peu plus nettement plus
que son besoin pour pouvoir en cas de
problème comme ce que nous rencontrons
pouvoir faire donc 3 mois cette année
deuxième élément la difficulté dans
laquelle se retrouve un certain nombre
de producteurs c'est de pas être payé au
prix et qui rémunère leurs produits on
le voit sur le lait en particulier la
question n'est pas oui mais ma question
n'est pas annuler la question c'est
d'avoir des producteurs qui continuent à
trouver leur rémunération parce que
s'ils ne trouvent plus leur rémunération
ils vont vendre leurs animaux s'ils sont
pas assez bien payés ils vont vendre des
animaux et là il y aura moins de lait et
donc à ce moment là en plus mes
questions est-ce que à l'heure qu'il est
ou dans les semaines il y a pas de il y
a pas de risque de pénurie en tant que
tel le risque de rupture de la chaîne il
existe quand il y a un problème de
rémunération c'est pas un problème de
quantité initiale c'est ça que je vais
vous dire on ne manque pas de produit on
a une récolte de céréales qui est plutôt
à niveau mais quand vous dites
rémunération on sait bien que ce sont
les industriels ou la grande
distribution qui font que les
agriculteurs sont payés bien pas assez
bien on parle beaucoup de Total qui doit
faire des efforts pour l'essence par
exemple est-ce que vous demandez par
exemple à Carrefour à Leclerc de faire
des efforts pour mieux payer les
agriculteurs mais il me semble que les
efforts pour tenir l'inflation parce que
fait le gouvernement avec un plan qui a
été proposé amendait soutenu par la
première ministre et par la majorité par
un certain nombre d'autres d'ailleurs
c'est un plan qui vise à contenir
l'inflation et donc chacun doit faire sa
part et donc la grande distribution et
donc les transformateurs quand ils le
peuvent il faut que les efforts pour
contenir l'inflation soient fait et donc
vous dites à Carrefour comme un total
quoi mais il me semble que c'est la même
logique qui s'impose c'est euh dans
cette leçon sont inquiets et où la
rémunération de la chaîne alimentaire
n'est pas satisfaisante vous avez
aujourd'hui des prix du lait on vend le
litre à moins de 70 cm à 60 moins de 70
centimes on aurait une heure pas le prix
du lait on devrait plutôt d'ailleurs je
vois que un grand distributeur à 10 ça
devrait plutôt vers un euro et donc il
faut qu'il fasse la part mais ça peut
pas être sur le dos des agriculteurs
c'est à eux de faire la part du chemin
pour faire en sorte qu'il équilibre
économique se trouve les consommateurs
doivent s'attendre en tout cas une
augmentation du prix d'alimentation
c'est déjà le cas depuis quelques
semaines il va y avoir un chèque
inflation qui va être versé aux familles
les plus modestes à partir de septembre
à l'origine on parlait d'un chèque
alimentaire l'idée d'achat alimentaire
est-elle abandonnée non mais l'idée
d'abord on prend les choses dans l'ordre
dans cette affaire de l'inflation vous
parlez déjà d'un projet qui a été voté
cet été qui va se mettre en oeuvre au
mois de septembre on enverra les effets
on verra aussi les effets d'inflation et
l'idée qu'on puisse aider les plus les
plus modestes à accéder à une
alimentation et deuxième élément à
accéder c'est pas la moindre des choses
à une alimentation de qualité c'est à
dire qu'il soit suffisamment diversifié
certains produits bien ciblés c'est il
me semble que c'est un élément de
pouvoir accéder à des fruits et légumes
frais c'est un élément qui est un
élément sanitaire de santé
et donc on regardera dans les mois qui
viennent mais ce qu'il faut regarder
d'abord c'est ce qu'on fait à la rentrée
on fait un effort signification
100 € + 1 alimentaire pourrait avoir
lieu en 2023 par exemple c'est dans
cette perspective là que la question
devra se poser me semble-t-il 2023 dans
cette perspective là mais il faut le
faire aussi dans une logique qui soit
une logique d'équilibre global du marché
chacun doit faire ça par l'État on peut
pas à chaque fois dire c'est à l'état de
fer il faut aussi ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure pour les opérateurs fassent leur
être à propos des tas de l'État les
éleveurs notamment disent nous avec la
séchage on a subi d'énormes pertes il
l'estime pour l'un des syndicats à 3
milliards de pertes va-t-il y avoir des
aides directes financières aux érupteurs
versés par l'État alors il y a d'abord
ce que j'ai annoncé la semaine dernière
qui est une première mesure c'est une
mesure parce que la vérité c'est ce que
disent d'ailleurs les actes qui vont
être devancées mais je le répète parce
que les éleveurs ils ont un sujet de
venteux c'est de ne pas avoir la
trésorerie pour pouvoir payer
présentation du bêta qui parfois ils se
fournissent dans cette alimentation
ils se fournissent en cette alimentation
en octobre novembre décembre et là ils
sont obligés de le faire dès aujourd'hui
donc on a accéléré les avances de la
politique agricole commune c'est au 16
octobre il y a un milliard 5 de plus de
trésorerie qui sera faite deuxième
élément est-ce qu'il va y avoir un
impôts sécheresse non il y aura pas
d'imposer je reste deuxième élément
construit au rendez-vous de la
solidarité je vais vous expliquer
comment d'abord les calamités sécheresse
qu'on active dans une temporalité
beaucoup plus rapide pour faire en sorte
que ça soit pas dans 6 ou 8 mois que
c'est calamité soit mise à l'oeuvre et
qu'à la limitée il y a des critères que
tous les agriculteurs qui ont droit au
calamités auront calamité difficile à
chiffrer aujourd'hui évidemment puisque
le maïs il est encore le fourrage on
verra ce qui sera rentré mais évidemment
on sera rendu fou et ça c'est de
l'argent qui viendra compenser la perte
deuxième élément d'annonce que je peux
faire on va moduler les critères qui
étaient peut-être trop restrictif pour
faire en sorte que plus d'agriculteurs
je pense au polycluteur élevage puisse
accéder au calamité s'échauffe troisième
élément on va faire en sorte que ce
qu'on appelle la taxe sur le foncierne
empathique et payé par les agriculteurs
soit dégradés d'office c'est-à-dire que
par nature les services fiscaux
départemental dès lors que le calamité
sécheresse est avérée et puis c'était
dégravé de cette impôts et puis dernier
élément on est en train de réfléchir
avec la première ministre à un fond
d'urgence comme on l'a fait sur d'autres
mesures qui permettra de soulager alors
ça c'est de l'adoucie c'est les directs
de l'État aussi tout ça c'est de l'aide
oui mais là c'est des chèques oui mais
les calanité c'est un château mais là ce
que vous annoncez là c'est le chèque de
l'État oui bien sûr mais les calamités
c'est les moyens de l'État oui oui
pardon je vous laisse regarder qui
permettra pour les situations les plus
délicates mais ça vous comprendrez que
ça a besoin d'être expertisé les
situations les plus délicates qu'on
puisse faire en sorte aucun éleveur en
particulier aucun éleveur ne soit mis
sur le le bord du chemin et puis dernier
élément une réforme dont on parle pas
mais qui est une réforme qu'on est en
train de travailler de finaliser que la
réforme de l'assurance récolte qui
permettra de mieux couvrir ses risques
là parce qu'on voit bien que les
dérèglements climatique sont devant nous
et que cet été j'espère que ça n'est pas
un été test au sens qui sera l'été
modèle entre guillemets mais
malheureusement voilà série sont avérées
je compare la question de l'utilisation
de l'eau parce que le débat était
relancé autour des projets de réserve
dans les Deux Sèvres en
Charente-Maritime les bassines qui sont
des grands réservoirs de dizaines
d'hectares qui permettent de capter
l'eau de la pluie mais c'est aussi de
l'eau qui vient des nappes phréatiques
parfois sur Twitter vous avez apporté
votre soutien aux agriculteurs parce
qu'il y a des opérations de saccage qui
avait été soutenu notamment par Europe
Écologie Les Verts est-ce que vous
comprenez cependant que ces pompages
dans les nappes phréatiques puissent
faire débats mais ces projets dont vous
parlez sont des projets légaux j'ai pas
dit ça non est-ce que vous comprenez
des débats c'est une chose mais qu'on
vient de détruire le bien d'autrui qu'on
vient de rentrer sur des propriétés ça
c'est pas acceptable
je vous ré signalé la grande
responsabilité qui a été celle des
agriculteurs cet été mon collègue Béchu
le disait au Conseil des ministres c'est
eu des tas de contrôle les agriculteurs
sont très marginaux dans les fraudes sur
ces affaires d'accès à l'eau pourquoi
parce qu'ils ont un esprit de
responsabilité donc j'invite tout le
monde à voir le même esprit de
responsabilité directement
responsables ils ne respectent pas la
loi dans une démocratie on respecte la
loi même si elle ne vous plaît pas on
respecte la loi et deuxième élément sur
ces sujets même de l'eau la vérité c'est
le combat multimillénaire des
agriculteurs c'est un combat d'accès à
l'eau c'est pas nouveau ce sujet non
c'est sûr pour pour alimenter les gens
il faut avoir accès à l'eau certains
disent c'est de l'eau que les
agriculteurs captent pour eux-mêmes
capables pour eux-mêmes quand vous me
méprenez de l'eau pour des salades pour
des tomates pour les maïs et pour le
maïs il sera disputé non mais le maïs il
sera alimenté le bétail est-ce que ça
peut disputer vous venez
vous venez de m'interroger en disant
qu'est-ce que vous faites pour les
agriculteurs qui perdent du maïs qui
peuvent pas alimenter leur bétail donc
ça sert à quelque chose est-ce qu'on
peut changer après passer à autre chose
à prendre la première c'est dans les
régions qui sont les plus en difficulté
en termes de sécheresse de regarder
comment réoriente et déjà il y a un
certain nombre de régions la culture de
mai ça diminué et on la remplace deux
c'est d'avoir des systèmes qui soient
plus économes en eau il y a dans le plan
de relance et dans France de 1030 des
centaines de millions d'euros qui sont
prévus pour ça il y a déjà 50 millions
qui ont été débloqués récemment pour ce
pour ces sujets là et puis troisième
élément on a besoin d'avoir accès à
l'eau parce que le dérèglement
climatique alors il nécessite d'avoir
accès à l'eau alors ça veut dire que ça
veut dire pardon peut-être qu'il faut
qu'on dans bien des endroits multiplier
les usages de l'eau j'étais l'autre jour
dans les Alpes-de-Haute
en aval de Serre-Ponçon s'il y avait pas
Serre-Ponçon aujourd'hui on aurait des
problèmes d'eau potable on aurait des
problèmes d'alimentation vous dites-vous
il faut construire plus de retenue d'eau
plus de bassine je dis non le besoin en
eau il est
importants
aussi par des équipements qui sont
prévus dans le varen de l'eau qu'il faut
faire est-ce que vous je vous êtes tous
les retenus d'eau qu'on vient de voir je
vous réponds que dès lors que ça tient
compte ça prend en compte
l'environnement que on vient récupérer
l'eau superficiel qui vient en trop
depuis seulement celle-là que ça peut
être du multi-usage c'est aussi le cas
et que c'est fait dans les règles de
l'art et compris environnemental il faut
y être favorable parce que sinon il y
aura plus c'est pas la peine de se
raconter l'histoire une tomate mais
c'est c'est ce que je vous disais mais
j'essaye d'être de dire précisément les
choses une tomate c'est 95% d'eau donc
s'il y a pas d'eau il y a pas de tomates
d'accord donc il faut se dire les choses
simplement et puis il faut multiplier
multi-âge je dis un dernier point on
travaille pas c'est aussi par exemple en
France la réutilisation des eaux des
stations d'épuration en France c'est 1%
en Italie c'est 14% en Espagne c'est 8%.
donc il faut qu'on ait une culture de
l'eau d'utilisation de l'eau qu'on
n'utilise pas et qu'on pourrait
mobiliser plus plus facilement ils vont
revenir probablement avec le fond vert
d'isabeth mais d'abord c'est l'heure de
la rentrée politique et à gauche en
particulier tout le monde est déjà sur
le pont
la météo politique est-elle vraiment au
beau fixe à gauche l'Union résiste mais
la rentrée est dispersée la majorité qui
voulait renaître de ses cendres cherche
toujours sa vedette
chez les insoumis ont théâtralise le
débat et les ministres en recherche de
notoriété si presse
moi je vous respecte j'ai peur de rien
j'ai peur de personne mais j'ai
certainement pas peur du débat même pas
peur les insoumis seraient donc devenus
fréquentables d'une université à l'autre
les partenaires de la nupesse se rendent
visibles
vous savez bien on cherche depuis
longtemps à établir une relation de
confiance les uns avec les autres là le
fait de pouvoir se rendre visite et
travailler de concert en fait c'est
presque la matérialisation de cette
coalition désormais faudra compter avec
avec la nups comptez aussi avec Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui quoi que désormais sans
mandat prophétise les combats à venir la
rentrée avec les réformes qui arrivent
de l'assurance chômage des retraites
et sans doute assez frontal puisque
monsieur Macron a décidé de l'être
frontale à Metz pendant ce temps les
marcheurs font une innovation à une
première ministre souriante qui
n'apporte pas pourtant que des bonnes
nouvelles
nous devrons conduire des réformes oui
chacun devra prendre sa part les
entreprises notamment devront prendre
leur responsabilité la nouvelle maison
Renaissance ne suffira pas au
gouvernement pour voter et appliquer ses
réformes peut-être le moment pour les
Alliés historiques comme le modèle de
faire entendre leur voix
et donc il faut être d'autant plus
soudé et en politique la division c'est
la mort et là aujourd'hui vous êtes
content du poids du modèle dans la
nouvelle majorité ça n'est pas un point
qui se discute on ne fait jamais de
marche à l'âge
voilà on va parler de François Bayrou
tout à l'heure mais Marc filo le
quinquennat il est placé sous signe de
la transition écologique Elisabeth borne
a commencé à détailler aujourd'hui dans
Le Parisien son fond vert de 1 milliard
et demi avant de présenter ce qui sera
son plan de sobriété énergétique tous
les secteurs doivent participer
l'agriculture ce sera quoi ou
l'agroalimentaire l'agriculture c'est
déjà des plans qui sont développés j'en
ai mis un mot tout à l'heure au travers
de France 2030
et s'il y a besoin d'accélérer on le
fera en fonction des besoins qui peuvent
être j'ai cité la question de l'eau la
question de l'équipement pour faire en
sorte d'avoir un meilleur accès à l'eau
et donc c'est là dedans que ça
s'inscrira là le fond vert qui est
proposé qui est indiqué par la première
ministre un fond vert en direction des
collectivités donc c'est plutôt la
transition énergétique peut-être de
biodiversité aussi donc il faut que
chacun prenne sa part et donc l'étape
prend sa part pour accompagner les
collectivités pour accélérer au fond
mais ça veut dire qu'ils agriculteurs et
l'agroalimentaire devront prendre leur
part aussi mais ils prendront leur part
ils le font déjà ils le font déjà quand
vous verrez je vais beaucoup sur le
terrain il faut accélérer mais il faut
faire une transition vous voyez bien la
situation dans laquelle sont les
agriculteurs je lui disais tout à
l'heure dans le reportage beaucoup de
crises des prix qui sont pas au
rendez-vous et donc il faut les
accompagner financièrement pour faire en
sorte
c'est ça l'urgence on va accueillir
maintenant Nathalie Mauric et jean-y
poétique dans les quotidiens région du
groupe Ebra pour la carte blanche et
bras dont le Républicain Lorrain
[Musique]
bonjour Nathalie les députés sont à
pénéliques que déjà certains pensent à
l'avenir absolument
Marco votre partie le modèle vient de
déposer un texte
pour la pour voter la proportionnelle et
qui sera discutée dès le mois d'octobre
à l'Assemblée nationale alors on peut
vous reconnaître le mérite de la de la
cohérence et de la constance puisque la
proportionnelle c'est vraiment votre
combat politique depuis des années mais
à l'heure où vous en avez déjà parlé il
y a des crises qui climatiques terribles
à l'heure où l'inflation galope est-ce
que c'était cette proportionnelle une
priorité suffisamment
urgente pour en faire votre premier
texte discuter à l'assemblée
des relations avec le Parlement je
rappelle que pour avoir un texte dans
une niche parlementaire c'est comme ça
c'est pour vous parler il faut l'avoir
déposé un mois et demi avant mais est-ce
que c'était ça l'urgence c'est votre
premier laissez-moi c'est ce qu'on fait
les députés du groupe modem de mon
groupe il débattront au début du mois de
septembre de l'opportunité ou non de
l'inscrire simplement il est toujours
important de rappeler ce qu'on était sur
ces sujets là les volontés du groupe
modem j'ajoute une chose il me semble
que
on a un sujet institutionnel plus vaste
que la proportionnelle la question de
l'équilibre des pouvoirs la question du
travail parlementaire la question de la
proportionnelle aussi la question du
financement de la vie publique tout ça
c'est des sujets qui sont sur la table à
quel moment ils le font ils ont
décidément au mois de septembre pour
l'instant la décision n'est pas prise
pour dire des choses très classe c'est
pas sûr que ce soit en octobre mais non
mais c'est important de dire que ce
sujet là est un sujet qui reste
important dans la vie politique est-ce
que c'est une façon de marquer votre
spécificité et de dire quelque part au
président de la République ça devait se
faire durant le premier quinquennat là
ça ne s'est pas fait nous on pose cette
proposition nous avons continué notre
spécificité sur les sujets
institutionnels et sur la volonté de
réformer c'est une promesse qui a pas
été tenue quoi mais par ailleurs il y a
d'autres sujets sur lesquels le
Mouvement Démocrate s'exprime sur les
questions de pouvoir d'achat
des entreprises sur les questions
environnementales et donc c'est une
panoplie de texte et une Pan
d'intervention que veut porter le
Mouvement Démocrate et c'est bien
naturel que dans la majorité il fasse
entendre sa propre voix alors
pour être clair est-ce que franchement
cette proposition de loi qui encore une
fois fait partie des premières
propositions de loi que vous allez
proposer est-ce que c'est une façon
d'être prêt pour vous en cas de
dissolution pendant ce quinquennat vous
reconnaîtrez que ce sujet la
proportionnel on l'avait évoqué avant
qu'on soit dans la situation dans
laquelle on est à l'Assemblée nationale
moi je suis ministre du gouvernement mes
collègues sont parlementaires je vous
assure que ce qu'ils ont en tête c'est
de réfléchir au texte qui peuvent être
utiles pour le pays la question
institutionnelle est utile pour le pays
mais vous l'avez dit vous-même il y a
bien d'autres sujets qui sont utilisés
est-ce que vous pensez que la
dissolution est un risque vous qui
connaissez bien les équilibres il y a
jamais un risque il y a un processus
démocratique un processus de vote mais
on est dans une situation où je pense
que la première chose qu'on doit penser
c'est de s'atteler alors difficulté on a
évoqué est-ce que vous pensez que ce
quinquennat va se terminer sans
dissolution mais j'en sais rien c'est
c'est pas la volonté du gouvernement
c'est pas la volonté de la majorité
après dans quelle situation de blocage
ou pas on peut être parce que des
oppositions des jours et la politique du
pire j'entendais Monsieur Mélenchon
disant hier faut se préparer des à
présent la proportionnelle moi je pense
qu'il faut se préparer plutôt au sujet
énergétique au sujet de transition
écologique au sujet de pouvoir d'achat
et pas se projeter immédiatement dans un
sujet qui est un sujet éminemment
politique oui mais bien sûr que ceux qui
nous regardent ils se fichent un peu de
savoir s'il y a de la dissolution ils
sont par contre très préoccupés de l'été
et on en a parlé sur les questions
non mais pardon
les sujets de souveraineté alimentaire
l'arme alimentaire c'est politique en ce
moment c'est quand même vous c'est votre
groupe qui mettait cette proposition de
loi sur le tapis donc c'est normal il
pose la question
je vous dis que c'est la panoplie des
choses mais vous me posez la question de
la dissolution je vous dis que le sujet
de l'Assemblée nationale d'accord donc
la proportionnelle ce serait quoi ce
serait une partie celle que vous
proposez là ou est-ce que ça risque
d'être est-ce que ça ce texte là peut
être voté
Jean-Paul Mathey de discuter avec les
autres formations politiques j'ai
toujours entendu sur la place publique
un certain nombre de formations
politiques à gauche et à droite
comme bien d'autres sujets c'est des
sujets où on vote avec l'opposition de
ben c'est pas nouveau j'ai pas attendu
le mois de juin pour penser que ce
serait bien que dans ce pays on se
préoccupe de l'intérêt général
institutionnel pouvoir d'achat
transition écologique plutôt que d'être
si chacun dans son coin à se regarder en
chaîne faïence justement vous parliez
justement des équilibres depuis le début
du quinquennat donc depuis trois mois
les LR les républicains ont un rôle
central à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
aujourd'hui la force d'appoint de de la
majorité en clair c'est eux qui ont la
clé pour faire passer les réformes de
votre gouvernement est-ce que c'est un
problème mais on est dans un majorité
relative toute personne qui veut faire
avancer le pays sur les réformes qui ne
paraissent utiles et qui nous rejoignent
sans se renoncer à ce qu'ils sont je
demande pas au LR aux autres ou aux
parties socialistes aux autres de
renoncer ce qu'ils sont et que dans le
de crise que nous traversons soit pas
capable de passer par-dessus les
frontières c'est un vieux combat pour le
coup du Mouvement Démocrate et de
François Bayrou que celui de dire il
faut dépasser les clivage oui tous les
sujets qu'on a évoqué vous croyez pas
que ça mériterait de dépasser l'équivage
et de sortir des postures donc ici ça
peut être les LR et j'espère que dans
d'autres cas ça sera d'autre qui nous
rejoindront pour essayer de réformer ce
pays par exemple des lois sont votées
avec le rassemblement national ça non
c'était pas à eux que je pensais mais
vous pensiez être sur le je pensais sur
le flanc gauche je trouve regrettable
que sur le flanc gauche des gens qui
pourraient ne pas être très éloignés sur
un certain temps par exemple sur le
Parti socialiste ou l'Europe écologie
sur la question de la transition
écologique soit dans une dans une
posture qui est une posture du nom moi
je le regrette avez-vous le sentiment
que votre groupe le MoDem a moins de
poids à l'Assemblée avec cette majorité
relative bah il a tout autant de poids
puisque
avec 50 députés évidemment il pèse aussi
lourd que ce qui pesait précédemment me
semble-t-il et donc sa voix est attendue
et sa voix est entendue dernière
question la République en marche hier
avec ces deux satellites est en train de
créer un nouveau parti qui va s'appeler
Renaissance ça s'est passé hier à Metz
on l'a vu dans le sujet en clair il
prépare l'après Macron ça se passe sans
vous vous trouvez ça normal mais le
choix qu'on a fait c'est d'être allié
d'être lié les uns les autres d'être
solidaire et en même temps de porter
notre propre identité donc ça se fait
pas son nom ça se fera avec nous ça sera
avec nous vous dites parce que il était
pas sur un moment annoncé vous dites que
c'est pour préparer l'après c'est pas
pour préparer la presse c'est pour
préparer le maintien
mais là vous êtes dans une affaire qui
est une affaire interne je vous assure
j'ai été de ceux qui ont mené les
négociations au législatives je vous
assure que ça s'est fait un certain
nombre de gens qui sont sur cette photo
présent dans de bonnes conditions
d'alliance mais que nous portions chacun
notre identité est une chose qui me
paraît importante dans la diversité on
peut pas défendre à la fois la
proportionnelle défendre la diversité
politique la biodiversité si vous
permettez cette expression politique et
dire tout le monde dans le même régime
merci Nathalie
vous êtes le ministre aussi en charge du
bien-être animal et la sécheresse a
aussi fragilisé les animaux sauvages ce
sont des associations de défense de
l'environnement qui le disent elles
demandent d'ailleurs le report de la
date d'ouverture de la chasse de
certaines espèces parce que c'est gibier
là ont été fragilisés est-ce que quel
est votre position alors c'est pas dans
mon registre mais je suis bien-être
animal des animaux d'élevage mais ça
n'empêche pas de question je trouve que
cette propension qu'on a en permanence
dès qu'on a un sujet au lieu de se
mettre autour de la table de jeter tout
d'un coup une interdiction comme ça en
public je vais vous donner plusieurs
éléments on a besoin de de la chasse y
compris pour les questions de régulation
de population vous avez une photo de
sang
sur sur les cultures on a besoin donc
que ça soit régulé donc évidemment pas
question de décaler l'ouverture
incendies et les chasseurs se posent la
question c'est naturel et le font
j'ajoute que dans bien des cas y compris
dans la période des incendies il y a
beaucoup de chasseurs qui sont venus
prêter aider à portée de la logistique
au pompier aux agriculteurs qui eux
aussi ont beaucoup pleuré pour les
incendies si on pouvait ne pas dresser
les gens contre les autres et vous
agriculture vous dites il y a pas
d'urgence à décaler la date d'urgence et
que quand il y a des cas précis on peut
se poser la question localement il y a
mais on peut se poser la question de
quel si il y avait un sujet particulier
précis j'ajoute que la plupart des
espèces dont on parle c'est des espèces
qui sont soumises à plancha c'est-à-dire
que pour beaucoup d'entre elles on ne
peut on ne peut tuer que le nombre qui
est décidé en début d'année enfin au
printemps au printemps quand Julien
Bayou d'Europe Écologie l'hiver dit il
faut poser les temps que le gibier se
reconquilleux nous a dans la même
semaine parler de l'interdiction des
jets d'interdiction des piscines
d'interdictions de la chasse si on
pouvait construire dans ce pays quelque
chose on a besoin avec aussi des
écologistes quand je dis raisonnable ça
veut pas dire qu'ils soient pas
ambitieux de construire autre chose que
de l'interdiction on a besoin des
agriculteurs pour traiter de ces
questions là on a besoin des chasseurs
pour parler de biodiversité il y a bien
des sujets sur lesquels les écologistes
et les chasseurs pourraient se retrouver
pour préserver la biodiversité pour
planter des et donc si on était plutôt
plutôt de jeter des oukas et des
interdictions essayer de construire ça
serait parfait merci Maxime